welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston this is a breakdown of the
Mandalorian season 3 episode 3 chapter
19 the convert but who is the convert of
this episode is it bogoton to the
children of the watch or the failed
conversion of Dr Pershing big a the
somehow in somehow Palpatine returns I'm
gonna break down all the Star Wars
Easter eggs and the interesting details
in this episode that you missed because
there were a whole bunch of them and
please subscribe to my new channel the
Deep dive for even Fuller analyzes in
the titles you love like my John Wick
Deep dive coming this weekend also if
you're going to WonderCon I'm going to
be doing a panel with other new rock
stars on Friday March 24th at 2 30 room
213 a b come hang out with us we open
back in the Living Waters of the mind's
Mandalore as Pokemon catches her breath
upon seeing the mythosar last episode
but now only sees eerie's Stillness then
Jaron wakes up and notice grogu pets him
with his hand he might have been using a
bit of force healing to resuscitate him
as Mando sits up Pokemon's helmet light
scans from side to side searching that
water surface for any Ripple or any air
bubble bocaton says the water wasn't
always so deep but the bombings of The
Purge must have triggered seismic
activity so the mythosar wasn't always
down here but the thought to be extinct
creatures were merely dormant in the
night of a thousand tears cracked the
caves enough to clear a path for the
mythosar to swim up but pokeaton does
not tell din about that mythosar either
out of disbelief or out of distrust of
den she wants to keep this secret to
herself perhaps one day prove herself by
writing to this mythosar as pointed out
at the end of this episode leaves her
helmet on while piloting back to
calabala as if the old ways of Mandalore
had been spooked back into her at the
sight of mythosar din says this is the
way bogoton says this is the way and
grogu says yeah this is definitely him
trying to vocalize this is the way but
it sounds like his first steps in a
babbling might have been inspired by the
end zealans whom he hugged back on
Navarro when the trouble starts he too
helmets up with the lid but he only does
so when din leaves because it didn't
stayed he would have felt protected by
Papa they're attacked by Thai
interceptors and vocotan says I've
skugged off a lot of Imperial Warlords
skug is a zigerian insult in Star Wars
and I think one of those Warlords one of
the few who could still even be out
there the one who sent this Fleet is
Grand Admiral thrawn because even both
seems surprise later saying that's a lot
of ships for an imperial warlord we get
a burst of Ludwig Jordan's flute as
Favreau Works in an Iron Man 2 Skydive
of Mando from The Gauntlet and I love
how Amanda waits to ignite his jetpack
until after the interceptors have
cleared because if he had hovered too
slowly they would be able to pick him
off Dan takes off fast in an in one not
boost Starfighter as he ascends beneath
him on that Landing Pad a second later
an explosion tears through where the N1
just was he climbs and then tips over
hammer heads to get a clean shot of the
Interceptor and then tilts the nose to
clear the explosion and I love that they
show the wreckage of the Interceptor
crashing in the Water behind him it's
just such a well-directed dog fight
pokotan tells R5 that she grew up flying
these Cliffs and immediately scrapes The
Gauntlet on the cliff wall three tie
bombers bomb the out of poketan's
Castle she calls them mud scuffers son
of a mudscuffer was used by Cara Dune in
the season 2 finale Bo chases them down
and behind her you can see R5 twisting
its Dome as if to say no don't do it
they zip off in hyperspace and then we
move on to Coruscant this is the latest
in history we've seen it in live action
since George Lucas version The Return of
the Jedi special edition during that
celebration Montage now this new
Republic era of Coruscant is colorful
and Lively compared to the brutalist
authoritarian monotones it wasn't Andor
during the Imperial era a new Republic
amnesty officer walks in late adjusting
her uniform and her badge this is g68
AKA Elia Kane Katie O'Brien who played
gentura in Ant-Man the Watts guanamania
and was last seen as mob Gideon's
communication officer in season two her
Hasty arrival is a clue that she's not a
real fan she's on a job to scope out
Pershing and her name Elia Kane as in a
liar and Kane or alternate spelling Kane
the brother in Genesis who betrayed Abel
now this is the same exact opera house
from Revenge of the Sith where Palpatine
told Anakin the tragedy of Darth
Plagueis the Wise which is ironic
because Alaya Kane I believe is an agent
for Palpatine's Immortal Legacy Pershing
is the beneficiary of the new Republic
amnesty program in which ex-imperials
are given Second Chances based on the
post-world War II Operation Paperclip in
which Nazi scientists like Werner Von
Braun were welcomed into the U.S
military establishment to help US during
the Cold War and win the moon race
Pershing says his research was twisted
into something cruel and inhumane the
best of an individual intent on using
cloning technology to secure more power
for himself referring to the genetics
research he had been doing in the past
two seasons on behalf of mock Gideon on
the child grogu we first saw in chapter
3 from season one now we are now a
decade after the battle of endors so
it's just interesting that the new
Republic would still extend amnesty to
imps who served war criminals this late
after the war or fawn over them and
their now illegal cloning research at
public TED Talks this just shows how
flawed the new Republic is currently and
how vulnerable it is to the rise of the
first order like historically the United
States recruited Warner Von Braun but
Von Braun didn't keep building rockets
for like Rogue Nazi SS officers 10 years
after World War II as Persian says he
now wants to help the new Republic his
hands in the hollow display behind him
nervously fidget and he says that his
original intentions were good and he
tugs his ear and we cut back to Alia
reading it as his poker tell him
touching his ear is actually a callback
from when Cara Dune and didn't jaran
took him in the season 2 finale Kira
shot that Imperial pilot in injuring
pershing's ear that pilot was bragging
about the Empire destroying Alderaan and
so Pershing really is flashing back the
whole idea of Imperial cruelty he tells
the story of his mother's heart getting
out and wishing he had simple organ
cloning he says he just wanted it for
organ transplants and he credits the
Kami noans for their work these were the
ones who created the army of clones from
Jango Fett and a bad batch one of those
coming Owens is currently Imperial
holding for some secret project that's
probably connected to this but rushing
says rather than one strand he could
combine the best genetic attributes from
both donors which kind of feels like a
dig at the bad batch because they were
the opposite of this the worst strands
but also sets up the research that will
be used by Palpatine's cloners the whole
idea here is probably to use a mix of
genetic material with high imp count
from grogu and existing samples that
Palpatine provided before die after this
Persian tells the fan the first casts
rejected the formula almost immediately
perhaps referring to that gooey
pre-snoke strandcast that we saw in the
tank in the Navarro Basin season two
Persian is mobbed by Coruscant
Aristocrats one of whom brags about
being a draft Dodger and not knowing the
difference between the Empire the rebels
and the numer Republic this crowd just
sounds like Eugenics fetishists who now
get away with their Devil's advocacy
because they're now fortunate to live in
an open Society thank you to better help
for sponsoring this video movies and TV
great escapism but when it's time to
face things that on betterhelp is here
to help better help is the world's
largest therapy service and it's 100
online with better help you can tap into
a network of over 25 000 licensed and
experienced therapists who can help you
with a wide range of issues to get
started just answer a few questions
about what you're looking for from
therapy and what your preferences are
better help will then match you with a
therapist from their Network that's
right for you after that talk to your
therapist however you feel comfortable
whether that's via text chat phone or
video call you can message your
therapist at any time and schedule live
sessions when it's convenient for you if
your therapist isn't the right fit for
any reason you can switch to a new
therapist at no additional charge
betterhelp gives you the same level of
professionalism and quality you expect
from in-office therapy but with a
therapist who is custom picked for you
more scheduling flexibility and at a
more affordable price get 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com new
rockstars that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p.com new rockstars
for 10 off your first month of therapy
the taxi Droid is actually the same
model as Ralph McCrory's original
concept art receipt 3PO he's voiced by
Dylan for Sheen an assistant editor on
the show internet commence the Sky Dome
botanical gardens which was mentioned in
a number of Legends novels in the my
cess blossoms that he mentions come from
The Wookie Planet Sheik that are found
in the game Star Wars Galaxies he
mentions an exhibit on hyperdrive
technology which could connect to the
rakatan Invaders that Luth and Rael
brought up in Andor episode 4 the
rakotans were also from Legends they
were the ancient inventors of hyperspace
technology but currently canonically
hyperspace technology was derived from
the pergil the hyperspace whales that
grogu just saw two episodes ago the taxi
Droid also mentions extinct animals like
the mantapog of malastar the mantabog
were Airborne blanket-shaped animals
that smothered their prey they're
actually mentioned an RPG Source book
Coruscant in the core worlds one of the
amnesty officers as he walks up says
Pudu we don't get promoted hoodoo again
meaning bad the fodder but I just love
that we overhear a couple of these
ex-nazis were given Second Chances
complaining about not getting promoted
when Pershing walks up m34 G27 M40 all
turn to look at him but g68 keeps her
head down initially because she is
expecting it we see how Pershing has a
new amnesty program badge which looks
like an elongated version of the orbash
a a for amnesty and for
they speculate on moff Gideon one Sadie
heard he escaped enroute to the war
tribunal the other saying that was just
a cover story I heard they hooked him up
to the Mind flayer now mind flayer was
first mentioned by Cara Dune in season 1
chapter 8. I'm a rebel shocks your
brother upload me to a mind player those
aren't real that was just wartime
propaganda and this episode shows it was
real Tech used by the Empire but now in
a lesser form used by the new Republic
to lobotomize or Eternal Sunshine or
Clockwork Orange someone's dark memories
and thoughts out of their minds but
Gideon escaping is the cover story why
would that be the preferable propaganda
that a war criminal escaped that would
be pretty embarrassing for the new
Republic right you think it would be the
opposite that they would say they
lobotomized someone who in actuality
Escape so if they did mind player him I
wonder if Elia Kane was behind that plan
and if the new Republic is actually more
concerned with being accused of torture
than they are worried about being seen
as having lacked security clearly they
just have messed up priorities that's
why the first order is going to get him
these guys reminisce on the little
things about serving the Empire you know
the uniforms a bit better the trains ran
on time those yummy yellow travel
biscuits also planetary genocide g68
says she preferred the red ones she also
eats a red popsicle because she's a
psychopath Pershing reads up on corsant
which a voice Wikipedia calls an
ecumenopolis referring to a planet-wide
city saying it's one of many also
referring to hosnian prime it goes on to
say though Coruscant is referred to as
the center of our galaxy it's precisely
located at our and then she gets cut off
but according to the Star Wars Galaxy
map while Coruscant is a core world
there's actually a more inner tier
called The Deep core with planets like
tython which we also saw in Mando season
2 and closest to the core bis which is
Palpatine's secret Throne world the fact
that this recording cuts off here might
be a clue that before hexagon rides the
Skywalker Palpatine's cloning Refuge was
actually biss and that is where his
Essence is currently hiding using snoke
to build up the first order Elia leaves
a whole crate of yellow Nazi cookies
still wrapped with that Imperial Crest
and orabesh E B maybe for Empire
biscuits the evilest of the Girl Scout
cookies which is also just the
shortbread Persian supervisor wishes
them a happy bendu day which is the
fifth and final day of the week so it's
kind of like saying happy Friday if
Friday was followed by another Monday
yeah because there's only like five days
of their week later they actually say
tongs days am I right so the order of
the dates of the week go Prima day
syntax day tongs day zelde and bendu day
tongs were actually the race that once
lived on Coruscant some of whom fled in
Legends continuity to found Mandalore
meanwhile bendu is that large Force
sensitive creature from adelon and
Rebels who helps Kanan Ezra repair their
friendship I love how these archive
discs look like the disc that was handed
to Leia at the end of Rogue one so this
just would be the hardware that they use
to store digital records the plaza that
Pershing and Kane visit is the same part
of course not that we saw in season two
of 14 and Clone Wars Duchess of
Mandalore where Obi-Wan met up with the
team the music we hear is actually a
carnival version of the march of the
resistance theme the magician is the
Cameo by Dean cundy one of the all-time
best cinematographers who worked on the
Back to the Future Trilogy Apollo 13
couple episodes of The Book of Boba Fett
he shot the Tuscan train Heist and works
on the Mandalorian his flash Cameo here
it's kind of like his Cameo as the 1885
photographer impact of the future 3 who
snaps Marty and Doc's photo be sure to
check out my back to the future because
that guy did amazing work now it's
interesting to watch Kane work Pershing
as person is ready to move on from his
Colony research but it's Kane who waits
for him to express the slightest
interest and encourages it like Russian
agents corrupting the office workers and
FX as the Americans she uses classic
appeals like getting into question
authority reframing what they're
actually doing is trying to help or just
doing a small rebellious act like
touching the peak of umate the highest
point on corsan Elias says it's the only
place on coruscott where you can see the
planet itself which is her way of
satisfying a need to what Pershing said
earlier about being overwhelmed by the
trillions of people on the planet a
trillion of anything's impossible for
someone to Fathom but one two-story rock
as their Everest Peak is tangible and
literally grounding for him Eli offers
to buy him a photon fizzle which is the
green beverage in the vat and dex's
Diner in Coruscant an attack at the
Clones which first originated in a 1985
episode of Star Wars droids the last
Prince Pershing has to check with his
parole officer Droid who's actually
voiced by Regina Hermosillo the set
decorator who works on the show I'd like
how you can see the buried annoyance of
Pershing when he has to sit through the
repair the question format do you have
any anger or resentment his cheek
Twitches just a little so impression ask
Kane for help notice the bushes they now
sit beside are dying hint that this is
actually a toxic manipulative
relationship so this episode shows two
Loops of pershing's workday routine the
first he's compliant not eager to ruffle
feathers after being activated by Kane
he now pushes back against his boss to
ask why they have to destroy Tech just
because it's Imperial his boss says not
only do we have the Imperial disposal
guards to inventory we're still
decommissioning the alliance Fleet they
are scaling back the Rebel Alliance Navy
that we saw in Return of the Jedi
something that we know at this point in
history Leia Organa is speaking out
against and she later takes off with her
independent Fleet that becomes the
resistance like all of us pursuing
snacks on a biscuit from his drawer
showing how he is now eating the
forbidden fruit poisoned Apple from Elia
he's snacking on the bait and he's
hooked so on the second Loop when his
parole Droid asks if he feels resentment
he tugs his ear these interviews feel
like the void comp test from Blade
Runner or Scientology auditing really
the questions are designed to provoke an
emotional response that can be used
against the interviewee first thing even
kind of looks like Rick Decker from
Blade Runner with that raised trench
coat collar in the Metro station they
pass a sign in orabesh federal station
executive building Monument partner
public transit system of Corazon has
zero tolerance policy on its rules and
restrictions report all violations
immediately on the train one guy raises
his newspaper reminding me of that
moment The Fugitive when that one L
train Rider in Chicago folds up the
newspaper to see Richard Kimble's face
on it this is Star Wars so I'm obligated
to point out all Harrison Ford parallels
and in The Fugitive and Blade Runner he
played Runners named Richard and let's
not forget these Droids Notting Indiana
Jones tickets Please bit in Last Crusade
only when they're on the train does Kane
reveal that they're going to sneak into
that Imperial disposal yard and she says
that's where she got the biscuits and
gives them this flirty little nudge in
spycraft this is textbook honeybody they
pass through the more industrial regions
of Coruscant where Darth Sidious was
known to take residence during attack of
the Clones where Dooku visited him this
is also where we saw yaddle die in Tales
of the Jedi so if Kane is working on
behalf of Palpatine's loyal forces she
might know her way around here from her
youth on corusign the fact that she knew
the exact moment to jump and laid on
that cushy pad tells us that she has
taken this route before they gaze upon
the Imperial Star Destroyer booming up
from From Below in frame other times in
Star Wars the Star Destroyers always
come from above these rodents Scurry
about one nods on a corner of a yellow
biscuit suggesting that Kane has
literally walked this path before or
Pershing is like Hansel and Gretel
following a trail of cookie crumbs to
the place where the witch will throw
them in an oven so what is Kane playing
in here she's obviously entrapping
Pershing for the new Republic but also
it seems like she wants an exact
inventory of what Pershing would need to
continue any kind of genetics research
and then to erase him as a possible
Squealer from what moth Gideon was
really planning and to remove Any Trail
linked Palpatine when Pershing asks her
what she wanted to be when she grew up
Kane steps back into the Shadows
symbolizing her deceit I think her
loyalty to Palpatine in the Empire
actually began at a young age outside
they Spotlight him with a hovercraft
marked in oribesh police they waited to
trap him until after leaving the Star
Destroyer so that way he couldn't hide
back in the Bellows of the ship the mon
calamari reintegration officer tells him
the Mind player won't be that bad he'll
just see some pleasant colors so in
addition to the memory erasing Tech from
Eternal Sunshine this also resembles the
tortuous brainwashing of 1984 or the
treatment that was applied to Alexander
Clockwork orange whereas here they use
Visions the Empire and Andor use sound
torture remember the sounds of dysonite
children screaming so the empire was
deaf to the billions of voices screaming
out to Terror suddenly silence whereas
the new Republic is now blind to the
blast of Starkiller base that
nuketosnian Prime Hershey meals of the
mon calamari it was a trap and that
Montgomery just looks around confused I
just appreciate that this Akbar
reference is completely lost on him now
the chill music in the background of
this room is the same music that plays
in Jabba's Palace when C-3PO arrives to
deliver Luke's message and return the
Jedi I just love how in both cases they
use these classic Star Wars themes in
this new diegetic form in Universe watch
it over this Kane straightens her
uniform once more as we saw her do in
her opening shot of this episode like
pershing's ear tug this is her poker
tell and she munches on a yellow biscuit
for saying she prefer the red ones was a
lot the Mind player beams go from
peaceful blue to evil red she is frying
his memories to erase any evidence of
what moth Gideon was doing in his
cloning plot with the child perhaps to
cover the tracks of snoke and Palpatine
in the first order and we end the
episode back with mando Boca time
returning to the covert from the
premiere episode Paws visla greets them
he's now played and I think voiced too
by Tate Fletcher in the past he's only
physicalized by Fletcher and voiced by
John Favreau but I think Tate Fletcher
voices him now too he asks who this
night owl is Boca time before becoming a
night owl actually fought alongside
paz's relative previously for a Time on
the death watch the armorer tests the
Water by repeating the opening shot of
this season pouring into the tempting
that to create the same green Shimmer
showing that it was the Living Waters of
Mandalore that the armorer uses every
time she casts a new piece of beskar the
armor says that since they both bathed
in the Living Waters by Creed they are
both redeemed and Pokemon truly has not
removed her helmet since that moment
possibisla though notice does not
congratulate them and it could be
because he suspects an ulterior motive
from Boca time she might be working an
angle because notice how this episode
ends with her gaze settling on the
mythosar as the only real witness to the
mythosar is that she never told didn't
join about that she may actually be
intending to infiltrate this cult to win
them over from the inside and a
challenge pause challenge the armorer
and most of all challenged in jarin who
currently wields a dark saber she wants
the rightful rule of the scatter
Mandalorian people because if you ever
want to rule a group of people you gotta
start with the most extreme Die Hard
True Believers drinking that Kool-Aid
hey please subscribe to our new channel
the Deep dive and support us by grabbing
something from the deep dive collection
at nerdright.shop or this Mando inspired
shirt you can follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at Eaves following rockstars And
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you'd love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]